They're calling this an almost unfathomable
amount of rain
hitting this part of Texas, guys.
With natural disasters in the news,
the country is being treated to a real-time
debate over the sins of so-called price gouging,
If you're price gouging in our state, I'm
going to go after you.
And I will shame you on national TV.
Defenders of gouging, including many libertarians,
stress that price hikes force customers to
prioritize their purchases
while incentivizing suppliers to bring necessities
to market.
Marking the price up, selling it high as hell.
So if jugs of water are selling at $10 a gallon,
businesses have a motivation to truck them
in.
One of the advantages of letting prices rise
is it forces people to make the tough decisions.
And at that price, no one’s going to use
that water to wash their cars.
Critics, however, say that it’s immoral
to use the price mechanism
to meter out essentials in a crisis.
You know we're gonna now see people coming
in from other states,
trying to sell generators for a thousand dollars
to take care of-
you know to hurt people in need.
It's disgusting, if anybody price gouges
this is not the time to take advantage of
our neighbors.
Yet both sides ignore a more-important reality:
Local and national businesses routinely give
away goods and services
much more efficiently than public-sector responders
or charities can manage.
We saw what was happening in Florida
we thought what could we do to help our neighbors
in Florida as well.
In the wake of Hurricane Harvey slamming Texas,
businesses pledged over $72 million in aid,
with over three dozen giving more than $1
million a piece.
Airbnb used its home-sharing network to set
up places for people to stay,
and the crowd-sourced mapping app Waze helped
the displaced find shelters.
Walmart, the left’s favorite corporate bogeyman,
pledged more $20 million and brought water
and food to the needy.
During Hurricane Katrina, the world’s largest
retailer trucked in relief
long after FEMA convoys stopped running.
We will also match those donations two to
one up to ten million dollars
bringing the whole total to thirty million.
Private sector aid gets less press than empty
shelves and gouging accusations,
but it also makes good business sense.
In some cases, price hikes during a crisis
are appropriate,
but most retailers know they’re better off
showing that they care about their customers
and aren’t out to take advantage of a bad
situation.
Successful businesses safeguard their reputations.
In The Wealth of Nations, Adam Smith wrote that he had
“never known much good done by” people motivated by charitable aims,”
but providing aid in disasters is every bit
as much a part of the free market
as more obvious forms of profit seeking.
If critics and defenders of gouging are really
interested in creating a better society,
they’d do well to help make this part of
the Invisible Hand visible to all.